Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. But then came astonishingly violent earthquakes and floods. And on one terrible day and night, all the warriors of Athens vanished beneath the earth. And out in the ocean, the island of Atlantis sank beneath the waves and disappeared utterly. And this is the reason why the sea in that region is now impassable. And it is impossible for any navigator to make his way across it. For there is thick mud just below the surface that impedes the progress of any ship.
感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。然而，令人震惊的剧烈地震和洪水随之而来。就在一个可怕的昼夜之间，雅典的所有勇士都沉入了地下。而在远洋之中，亚特兰蒂斯岛沉入波涛之下，彻底消失了。这就是为什么该海域如今无法通行、任何航海家都无法横渡的原因。因为海面下方有着厚厚的淤泥，阻碍了任何船只的前进。
The rubble left by the island as it subsided. So Tom Holland, that is friend of the rest is history, Plato. Is he? He's been elevated. What a friend to have. What a friend to have. Not merely a leading philosopher, I think it's fair to say. The greatest, I think.
那是该岛下沉时留下的废墟。那么，汤姆·霍兰，也就是“历史余音”的好朋友——柏拉图。是吗？他被抬举了。有这样的朋友真不错。有这样的朋友真不错。不仅仅是一位伟大的哲学家，我认为这样说很公平。我认为他是最伟大的。
Some would say the greatest. He's the author of Timaeus, and it's from Timaeus that that reading comes. So Plato is the first person to really mention Atlantis. I mean, absolutely. I mean, he absolutely is the first person to mention it. And you explained in the first episode how you think he's using Atlantis as a kind of political and cultural kind of metaphor, as a shorthand, reflecting on Athens's position at the end of the peloponnesian war athens's relationship with sparta with its own history its politics yeah um his his anxiety about the form of government um that is now running athens and it's the first i think it's
有人会说他是最伟大的。他是《蒂迈欧篇》的作者，而那段朗读就出自《蒂迈欧篇》。所以柏拉图是第一个真正提到亚特兰蒂斯的人。我是说，绝对是的。我的意思是，他绝对是第一个提到它的人。你在第一集里解释过，你认为他把亚特兰蒂斯当作一种政治和文化隐喻，一种简写形式，来反思雅典在伯罗奔尼撒战争结束时的处境、雅典与斯巴达的关系、雅典自身的历史以及政治——是的，嗯——他对于现在治理雅典的政府形式的焦虑。我认为这是
the first parody of of works of history yeah so exciting for us. But that's not a view that is held by most Atlantis enthusiasts. Chief among them, I'm not going to describe him as a friend of the rest is history. He's a friend of Netflix. And he is. Well, he's the father of the commissioner of documentaries on Netflix, isn't he? He is. Graham Hancock. He's Graham Hancock, the author of i don't
历史上第一部历史作品的恶搞，对我们来说太让人兴奋了。但这并不是大多数亚特兰蒂斯狂热爱好者所持有的观点。其中最主要的一位，我不会把他描述为“历史余音”的朋友。他是奈飞（Netflix）的朋友。他的确是。好吧，他就是奈飞纪录片委托人的父亲，对吧？他确实是。格雷厄姆·汉考克。他就是格雷厄姆·汉考克，也就是
know what they call magicians of the gods or whatever those books are called in which atlantis plays a very big part and we started the first episode by talking about graham hancock and i'm sure we'll return to graham hancock because plato comes up with the idea of atlantis and as you said last time it's sort of you know people are banding it around for a few centuries. And many of them don't think Plato means it seriously as a sort of genuine literal geographical description. Yeah. But there's a point at which Atlantis disappears from the conversation, isn't there, in the medieval period. And then it reappears.
我不知道他们把那些书叫什么，《上帝的指纹》还是什么，亚特兰蒂斯在其中扮演了非常重要的角色。我们在第一集开头谈到了格雷厄姆·汉考克，我确信我们还会再次谈到他，因为柏拉图提出了亚特兰蒂斯的想法，正如你上次所说，这有点像，你知道的，人们在几个世纪里一直到处谈论它。而且他们中的许多人并不认为柏拉图是认真的，把它当作一种真正字面意义上的地理描述。是的。但是，在某个时间点，亚特兰蒂斯从对话中消失了，对吧，在中世纪时期。然后它又重新出现了。
Why do you think it reappears? Because, as I say, the myth begins with Plato, and it's Plato who gives us really the two definitive accounts. But Plato, because he's writing in Greek, his writings are lost. Actually, ironically, pretty much apart from the Timaeus, but almost all his other writings are lost in the Middle Ages. And it's only with the rediscovery of Greek learning in the Renaissance that Plato's dialogues start to reappear in Latin Christendom. This is why over the course of the 16th century, people become more and more familiar with the idea of Atlantis. And the idea of Atlantis that we have at the moment, we think of it as being
你认为它为什么会重新出现？因为，正如我所说，神话始于柏拉图，而且正是柏拉图给我们提供了两个最权威的记载。但柏拉图因为是用希腊语写作的，他的著作失传了。事实上，具有讽刺意味的是，除了《蒂迈欧篇》几乎都保留下来了之外，他几乎所有其他的著作在中世纪都失传了。直到文艺复兴时期希腊学术的重新发现，柏拉图的对话录才开始在拉丁基督教世界重新出现。这就是为什么在整个16世纪，人们对亚特兰蒂斯的想法变得越来越熟悉。我们现在的亚特兰蒂斯观念，
ancient Greek, but I think it would be better to say that it's at least as modern as it is ancient. Because as the understanding of it evolves over the centuries since the renaissance it tells us an awful lot about the obsessions and the paranoias and the yearnings of modern europe yeah um and the way that those have evolved over time so it and i know i often use this phrase but it does hold an intriguing mirror up to evolving cultural and political trends in Western Europe. So in a way, this episode is not merely a sequel to the episode we did about Plato and Atlantis, but it's also a companion piece to the episodes we did about Columbus, isn't it? If you haven't listened to our episodes about Christopher Columbus, we did a four-part series.
我们认为它是古希腊的，但我认为最好说它既现代又古老。因为随着对它的理解在文艺复兴以来的几个世纪中不断演变，它向我们透露了大量关于现代欧洲的执念、偏执和渴望的信息，是的，嗯，以及这些执念、偏执和渴望是如何随时间演变的。所以它——我知道我经常用这个词——它确实为西欧不断演变的文化和政治趋势提供了一面耐人寻味的镜子。从某种意义上说，这一集不仅是我们关于柏拉图和亚特兰蒂斯的节目的续集，也是我们关于哥伦布的节目的姊妹篇，对吧？如果你还没听过我们关于克里斯托弗·哥伦布的节目，我们做过一个四部分的系列。
And at the beginning, we talked about how Columbus's head was full of all this stuff that he had read about strange islands out in the atlantic marco polo of course has gone off to cafe and columbus has read that um people are debating if there's a a legendary island called brazil out there somewhere across the north atlantic um there might be sort of strange folk memories of of greenland or of uh newfoundland the um the viking colony there yeah so do you think atlantis is revived as part of that sort of package i mean again we mentioned this at the end of the last episode what is intriguing is that atlantis is actually the dog that doesn't bark in the story of columb He doesn't mention it. But I think what happens, so there are various ways in which Plato's story is reinterpreted. And one of the ways in which
而在开头，我们谈到了哥伦布的脑子里全都是他读过的关于大西洋中神秘岛屿的东西，马可·波罗当然去了契丹，而哥伦布读过这些……人们在争论横跨北大西洋的某个地方是否存在一个传说中的岛屿叫巴西岛……那里可能保留着某种关于格陵兰岛或纽芬兰岛——也就是那里的维京人殖民地——的奇特民间记忆，是的。所以你认为亚特兰蒂斯作为那个大礼包的一部分而死灰复燃了吗？我的意思是，我们在上一集结束时也提到过这一点，有趣的是，亚特兰蒂斯实际上是哥伦布故事里那只没有叫的狗。他根本没提到它。但我认为发生的事情是，柏拉图的故事被以各种方式重新诠释了。其中一种诠释方式，
it's reinterpreted, I think is a direct result of the discovery of America. And that's the idea that there are survivors. So Plato says that the whole island sinks he doesn't mention survivors but when people get to america and they're trying to work out what it is it isn't long before people are referencing plato and thinking well maybe either this is atlantis obviously that's a problem because plato says that it sunk yeah or that there were survivors from Atlantis and they contributed towards the civilizations that people are finding in the new world. And that, of course, is very Graham Hancock, the idea that there is a lost clan of experts. I mean, that's basically the thesis of his stuff. Yes. So the idea that Atlantis is is an advanced civilization superior to the peoples of both
我认为是美洲被发现的直接结果。那就是存在幸存者的观点。因为柏拉图说整个岛屿都沉没了，他没有提到幸存者；但当人们到达美洲并试图弄清楚那是什么地方时，没过多久人们就开始引用柏拉图的观点，心想：要么这正是亚特兰蒂斯（显然这有问题，因为柏拉图说它沉没了），要么就是有亚特兰蒂斯的幸存者活了下来，他们为人们在新世界发现的那些文明做出了贡献。而这，当然非常符合格雷厄姆·汉考克的风格，也就是存在一族失落的专家的观点。我的意思是，这基本上就是他那一套东西的论点。是的。所以，亚特兰蒂斯是一个
america and europe and asia and africa and that essentially it's the people of atlantis who have instructed these less civilized peoples in the arts of civilization an absolutely key theme plato never said that they were never discussing that never mentions that so i think that that is absolutely expressive of an attempt by people in europe to work out, you know, who on earth are these people that we've found? Yeah. So you have this guy who's a historian of Cortez's expedition. I called Francisco Lopez de Gomara. Yes. Have you come across him?
超越了美洲、欧洲、亚洲和非洲人民的高级文明，基本上正是亚特兰蒂斯人教会了这些不够文明的人文明的艺术——这是一个绝对核心的主题。柏拉图从未说过这一点，从未讨论过这一点，也从未提及这一点。所以我认为这绝对表达了欧洲人试图弄清楚“我们发现的这群人到底是谁”的一种努力。是的。所以有这么一个人，他是科尔特斯远征的史学家。我叫他弗朗西斯科·洛佩斯·德·戈马拉。是的。你遇到过他吗？
I have, Tom, because I'm writing a children's book about the conquest of Mexico right now. So Gomara is in my thoughts all the time. He was Cortes' secretary. He went with Cortes so much later in life, not content with toppling the Aztecs, Cortes just went on an expedition to Algeria. And he never went to America, did he? So Gamara never went to the America. He never went to the New World. And his account of Cortes' life is generally seen
我遇到过，汤姆，因为我目前正在写一本关于征服墨西哥的儿童读物。所以戈马拉一直盘旋在我的脑海里。他是科尔特斯的秘书。他跟随科尔特斯度过了很晚的岁月，科尔特斯在推翻阿兹特克人之后还不满足，又去阿尔及利亚进行了一次远征。但他从未去过美洲，对吧？所以戈马拉从未去过美洲。他从未去过新世界。他关于科尔特斯生平的记述通常被视为
as a complete and utter hagiography. Sort of, you know, Cortes is, he sees Cortes as the epitome of gallantry and chivalry, and Cortes is credited with all these incredibly farsighted decisions, which most historians now say Gamara is talking nonsense. But Gamara is one of those sort of viewpoints we have into the Mexica, the Aztec civilization. And I see from your notes, Gamara is one of these people who says, well, where, the Aztec civilization. And I see from your notes, Gamara is one of these people who says, well, where did the Aztecs come from? They had migrated from a place called Aztlan. Yeah. And Aztecs means people from Aztlan.
彻底而完全的圣徒传记。某种程度上，你知道的，科尔特斯被他视为英勇和骑士精神的化身，科尔特斯被认为做出了所有这些极具远见的决定，而大多数历史学家现在认为戈马拉在胡说八道。但戈马拉是我们了解墨西加、阿兹特克文明的视角之一。我从你的笔记中看到，戈马拉正是那些提出“阿兹特克文明从哪里来”之类问题的人之一。他们是从一个叫做阿兹特兰的地方迁徙过来的。是的。而阿兹特克人就意味着来自阿兹特兰的人。
Yeah. And we now think when we had Camilla Townsend on our podcast, and she was talking about this, the author of the brilliant book, Fifth Son, about the Aztecs. People now think, don't they, that the Aztecs people now think don't know the aztecs migrated the mexica migrated overland from what's now new mexico or colorado or thereabouts and if there was an aslan some sort of folk memory of a starting point it was there but gamara thinks it could be atlantis brilliantly well because there is a certain phonetic resemblance isn't there i suppose so you know if you stand on your head and close your eyes and yeah aslan atlantis i mean kind of so so here's the thing the aztec mythology is all about islands and lakes because of course they end up in tenochtitlan which is mexico city which is
是的。我们现在认为——当我们请卡米拉·汤森上我们的播客时，她谈到了这一点，她也是关于阿兹特克的杰出图书《第五子》的作者——人们现在认为，难道不是吗？阿兹特克人，人们现在认为……不知道阿兹特克人是迁徙过来的，墨西加人是从现在的的新墨西哥州或科罗拉多州或其周边地区进行陆路迁徙的，如果曾经存在一个阿兹特兰、某种关于出发点的民间记忆，那也是在那里。但戈马拉认为它可能是亚特兰蒂斯，这真妙，因为确实存在某种语音上的相似性，对吧？我想是的，你知道的，如果你倒立着闭上眼睛，是的，阿兹特兰，亚特兰蒂斯，我的意思是，有点像。所以，事情是这样的：
an island and a lake so there's an island and it's not completely unreasonable that if you're sitting around in 16th century spain you hear about these people who do have an impressive civilization, who've come from an island and left and now migrated somewhere else, and you might think, oh, that makes sense. Okay, so this is where this kind of begins. And then there's another guy who's the bishop, the bishop of the Yucatan, Diego de Landa, who is much cursed both by the mayor and by historians of the mayor because he basically destroyed all the Mayan records.
阿兹特克的宗教学说完全围绕着岛屿和湖泊展开，因为他们最终定居在特诺奇蒂特兰，也就是墨西哥城，那是一座位于湖中的岛屿。所以这里有一个岛屿，如果你坐在16世纪的西班牙，听说有这样一群人拥有令人印象深刻的文明，他们来自一个岛屿，离开后又迁徙到了其他地方，你可能会想：哦，这说得通。好吧，这就是这种说法的起源。然后还有另一个人，那就是尤卡坦的主教迭戈·德·兰达，他深受玛雅人和玛雅历史学家的诅咒，因为他基本上摧毁了所有的玛雅记录。
He did what all historians secretly want to do. He made notes on the Mayan sources. He got rid of all the primary sources. He destroyed them so nobody else could ever read them. Yes. But he, among all the notes, he reports a story that supposedly is told by the mayor that their ancestors had come from a land in the east. Which, I mean, essentially it depends on scripts. He wasn't really qualified to decipher, I gather.
他做了所有历史学家私底下都想做的事。他记下了关于玛雅资料的笔记。他摆脱了所有的原始资料。他把它们全毁了，这样就再也没有人能读懂它们了。是的。但他，在所有的笔记中，记录了一个据称由玛雅人讲述的故事，说他们的祖先来自东方的一片土地。而这意味着，基本上这取决于他其实并没资格破译的手稿，据我所知。
And he could have been talking about Cozumel, which is an island off the coast of the Yucatan. Well, he could, Mr. Skeptic. He could. But equally, he could have been talking about atlantis oh right you want to keep that open as a possibility do you tom what i'm all i'm saying is that the evidence here is stacking up right aslan islands out and out in the east hold on they can't both be uh they can't both be atlantis surely they can yeah you can say that both the aztecs and the mayor come from atlantis basically everyone comes comes from Atlanta. That's not the maddest claim we'll be hearing on this podcast.
他当时说的可能是科苏梅尔岛，那是尤卡坦海岸外的一个岛屿。好吧，他完全可能，韦尔先生（Mr. Skeptic）。他确实可能。但同样地，他当时也可能在说亚特兰蒂斯。哦，对了，你想把这作为一种可能性保留下来，是吗，汤姆？我所要说的是，这里的证据正在不断堆积，对吧？阿兹特兰、向东延伸的岛屿……等等，它们不可能都是……它们不可能都是亚特兰蒂斯吧？当然可以，你可以说阿兹特克人和玛雅人都来自亚特兰蒂斯。基本上所有人都来自亚特兰蒂斯。这还算不上我们在本播客中听过的最疯狂的说法。
Oh, no. So that's one theme, the idea that there are survivors and that they might have colonized various reaches of the continents that have survived. The other idea, which is kind of implicit in that, is that Atlantis is a kind of utopia. It's a model of high civilization, which isn't at all what Plato says. I mean, Plato makes it out to be a fabulously wealthy and sophisticated place, but it gets destroyed because it's hubristic, because it is launching imperial invasions everywhere.
哦，绝对不算。所以这是一个主题，也就是存在幸存者，并且他们可能在各个大陆的幸存区域进行了殖民。另一种观点，其中也隐含着这一层意思，那就是亚特兰蒂斯是一种乌托邦。它是高度文明的典范，这与柏拉图的描述完全不同。我的意思是，柏拉图把它描绘成一个极其富裕和精致的地方，但它却被毁灭了，因为它的傲慢自大，因为它到处发动帝国主义入侵。
Plato is absolutely not saying that it's a model to be followed. In fact, just the opposite. I think it's a kind of fusion of the persian empire and um democratic athens and who isn't really keen on either of them but particularly in england so there's a thomas moore writes about utopia yeah this idea that there is a kind of perfect realm which is exactly that that time by the way it's 15 16 so it's exactly the moment when they're discovering Mexico and the Maya and all that stuff. And that idea of a kind of a land where, if you find it, you will have the model of a perfect realm, then gets picked up by Francis Bacon. Yes.
柏拉图绝对不是在说它是一个值得效仿的典范。事实上，恰恰相反。我认为它是波斯帝国和民主雅典的某种融合体，而柏拉图对这两者其实都不怎么感冒，尤其是在英国——托马斯·莫尔写过关于《乌托邦》的书，是的，这种存在一个完美国度的想法正是如此。顺便说一句，当时的时间是1516年，所以这恰好是他们发现墨西哥、玛雅以及所有这些东西的时刻。而那种如果你找到了它、你就会拥有一个完美国度模特的土地的想法，后来被弗朗西斯·培根采纳了。是的。
Who you will admire, Dominic, as the man who basically invented science. Yeah, the inventor of Lord Viscount St. Albans. He writes a book called The New Atlantis, which is actually a novel. So it's a kind of didactic novel right it's not particularly exciting not great characterization it's not the da vinci code it's not the da vinci code but it gives a kind of portrait of this island that supposedly is in the pacific and it's become christian it's i think they got converted by saint thomas but the key thing is is that it's full of people who we now would call scientists. People who live by reason, who
多米尼克，你一定会崇拜他，因为他基本上发明了科学。是的，圣阿尔班子爵勋爵的发明家。他写了一本书叫《新亚特兰蒂斯》，这实际上是一部小说。所以它是一种教诲性的小说，对吧？它不是特别惊心动魄，人物塑造也不算出色，它不是《达·芬奇密码》，它不是《达·芬奇密码》，但它描绘了这座据说位于太平洋中的岛屿的画像，它已经皈依了基督教，我想他们是由圣托马斯感化的，但关键在于，那里到处都是我们现在称之为科学家的人。那些依靠理性生活、
do experimentation, which Francis Bacon was very into. Bacon says that they embody generosity, enlightenment, dignity, and splendor, piety, and public spirit. And actually this kind of model of a community of high-minded people interested in the natural world goes on to serve as one of the inspirations to the Royal Society. What an amazing thing that this novel about an island of scientists inspires the Royal Society, which itself then inspires the Island of Scientists and Gulliver's Travels. Yeah, it just goes round and round and round. Yeah, amazing. So that's another part of the element. And the other thing, which again is implicit in
进行实验的人，而弗朗西斯·培根对此非常热衷。培根说，他们体现了慷慨、启蒙、尊严、辉煌、虔诚和公共精神。实际上，这种由志同道合、对自然世界感兴趣的人组成的社区模型，后来成为了皇家学会的灵感来源之一。这真是一件神奇的事，这本关于科学家岛屿的小说启发了皇家学会，而皇家学会反过来又启发了《格列佛游记》中的科学家岛。是的，它就是这样一圈一圈不断循环的。是的，太神奇了。所以这是另一个组成部分。而另一件事，同样隐含在
Francis Bacon's idea that Atlantis could exist in the Pacific, is that the location of Atlantis, it's moving around all over the place. I mean, just to reiterate, Plato is very clear where Atlantis was. It was beyond the Pillars of Hercules, in other words, the Straits of Gibraltar. So in the ocean that comes to be called the Atlantic after Atlantis. But Plato's obviously got it wrong if it's actually America or if it's in the Pacific and what you start to see as a kind of nationalism starts to develop so this is this is before the kind of heyday of romantic nationalism but the absolutely classic example of this is a guy called in the late 17th century who was the rector of the university of Uppsala
弗朗西斯·培根关于亚特兰蒂斯可以存在于太平洋的观点中，那就是亚特兰蒂斯的位置一直在四处移动。我的意思是，重申一下，柏拉图对亚特兰蒂斯在哪里说得非常清楚。它在海格力斯之柱之外，换句话说，就是直布罗陀海峡之外。因此，它位于因亚特兰蒂斯而得名的大西洋中。但如果它实际上是美洲或者位于太平洋，那么柏拉图显然就搞错了。随着某种民族主义开始抬头，你开始看到……所以这是在浪漫民族主义的全盛期之前，但其中绝对经典的例子是17世纪后期一个名叫……的人，他是乌普萨拉大学的校长，
and he does very detailed research into Atlantis. Research? What does this research consist of, Tom? So he's in Uppsala in Sweden. Where do you think he ends up saying that Atlantis was, Dominic? Finland? I don't know. Maybe it's the island of Gotland, Tom,
他对亚特兰蒂斯进行了非常详细的研究。研究？这种研究所包含的内容是什么，汤姆？所以他在瑞典的乌普萨拉。多米尼克，你觉得他最后会说亚特兰蒂斯在哪里？芬兰？我不知道。也许是哥特兰岛，汤姆，
which we've talked about in the podcast before. It's Sweden. Oh, it is Sweden. Where do you think the rector of the University of Uppsala locates the capital of Atlantis? Oh my god it's upsala the capital of atlantis was upsala amazing but true hold on but it's not an island that to me to me is the uh it's that's detail an absolute detail as we will see so and you see genuinely say he genuinely thinks this i think he does yeah and he proves it you know very learned to him okay
我们在之前的播客中谈到过。那是瑞典。哦，确实是瑞典。你觉得乌普萨拉大学的校长把亚特兰蒂斯的首都定位在哪里？天哪，是乌普萨拉！亚特兰蒂斯的首都竟然是乌普萨拉，太神奇了但千真万确！等等，但它不是一个岛屿啊。对我来说，这……这绝对是个细节问题，正如我们将会看到的。所以……而且你看到，他真的这么想，我认为他确实这么想。是的，而且他证明了这一点，对他来说相当博学。好吧，
have you read it no i haven't well let not put us off so dominic those are the basically the constituent elements there are there are survivors atlantis is a home of superior civilization yeah and basically the location of the island itself is a very movable feast but those so those examples you've given us they're all slightly different aren't they so the spanish guys in the 16th century i mean they can be forgiven for thinking anything because they're discovering new things all the time they you know it's easy for us to sort of mock and say haha they thought atlantis was you know colorado or something i mean columbus thought cuba was china right it's it's not a terrible sin to say that the Aztec Empire was Atlantis.
你读过吗？不，我没读过。好吧，那别让我们因此扫兴。所以，多米尼克，这些基本上就是构成要素：有幸存者；亚特兰蒂斯是高级文明的发源地，是的；而且该岛本身的位置基本上是一个变化不定的盛宴。但你给出的那些例子，它们其实各不相同，对吧？所以16th世纪的那些西班牙人，我的意思是，他们可以被原谅去想任何事情，因为他们一直在发现新事物。我们很容易去嘲笑并说“哈哈，他们以为亚特兰蒂斯是科罗拉多或其他地方”。我的意思是，哥伦布以为古巴是中国呢，对吧？说阿兹特克帝国就是亚特兰蒂斯，这算不上什么弥天大罪。
I mean, they don't know what we know. They're discovering stuff. It's completely reasonable. Francis Bacon is using it as Thomas
我的意思是，他们不知道我们所知道的。他们正在探索新事物。这完全合情合理。弗朗西斯·培根把它用作托马斯·莫尔
Moore was using utopia. He's using it as a political parable. The fellow from Sweden, he's probably the first example, I suppose, is he of
使用乌托邦的方式。他把它当作一个政治寓言。至于那个瑞典来的家伙，我想他大概是第一批
the sort of the slightly cranky conspiracy theorist who's basically hit on something that will you know make him look good and presumably his university yeah it's i mean essentially he's um he's drawing on you know he's taking words that sound a little bit like swedish you know the greek but words i mean what words i don't know i haven't read it yeah it's a bit like the um the davinci
有点古怪的阴谋论者的例子吧，他们基本上偶然发现了一些能让自己（以及推测还有他的大学）看起来很不错的东西。是的，我的意思是，本质上他是在利用……你知道的，他挑选了一些听起来有点像瑞典语的词，你知道的，希腊语的词……我是说，什么词？我不知道，我没读过。是的，这有点像《达·芬奇密码》里的那些东西，你有了你的想法，你希望它是瑞典。然后本质上，你只是去寻找任何可能支持这一点的东西。这就是你的做法。所以这大约三种元素在18世纪到19世纪期间不断发酵。并且有各种各样的迭代版本，它们借鉴了这些不同方面的其中之一。但绝对权威的记载来自一个基本上在发明亚特兰蒂斯方面仅次于柏拉图的人，
code stuff that you have you have your idea, you want it to be Sweden. And then essentially, you just look for anything that might support that. That's how you do it. So these kind of three elements are bubbling away over the course of the 18th into the 19th century. And there are various iterations of it that draw on one or other of these various aspects. But the absolutely definitive account comes from a guy who is essentially second only to plato in terms of um inventing atlantis yeah and this is a guy called ignatius donnelly yeah who is um he's a great character he's an irish stock american lawyer ends up republican congressman for minnesota yeah were you aware of
是的，这个人叫伊格内修斯·唐纳利。是的，他是一个了不起的人物，爱尔兰裔美国律师，后来成了明尼苏达州的共和党国会议员。是的，你了解
him i did yes because he was the vice presidential candidate of the populist party in uh 1900 he's a really interesting guy he's irish as you say but unlike a lot of irish sort of politicians in the 19th century he ends up in the republican party anti-svery, he's pro-women's suffrage. So he's quite progressive by and large. So his record during the Civil War, for example, his political record is pretty impressive. I read that he lived in the same place as me when I lived in Minnesota, St. Paul, Minnesota. Did he? Yeah. Oh, so no wonder you came across him then.
他吗？我知道，是的，因为他是1900年民粹主义党的副总统候选人。他是一个非常有趣的人。正如你所说，他是爱尔兰人，但与19世纪许多爱尔兰政客不同，他最终加入了共和党。他反奴隶制，支持妇女选举权。所以大体上他相当进步。因此他在内战期间的记录，例如他的政治记录，相当令人印象深刻。我读到过他和我住过同一个地方，当我住在明尼苏达州圣保罗的时候。是吗？是的。哦，难怪你遇到过他呢。
Well, I think it's just his name is sort of hanging around in late 19th century American politics. However, he's a sort of eccentric character because at one point he tried to set up a utopian community. Yeah. In Minnesota. In Nininga, which I don't think worked out at all. And when you look through his list of publications, so among other things, he wrote a big book about Francis Bacon writing Shakespeare.
好吧，我想只是他的名字在19世纪末的美国政治中经常出现。然而，他是一个古怪的人物，因为他曾一度试图建立一个乌托邦社区。是的，在明尼苏达州的尼宁格（Nininga），我觉得根本没有成功。当你浏览他的出版物列表时——除此之外，他还写了一本关于弗朗西斯·培根写了莎士比亚的大部头书。
Yes. Called The Great Cryptogram. Yes. Which perhaps gives you some sense of its scholarly worth. He wrote a book called Ragnarok, The Age of Fire and Gravel. So that's the sequel to Atlantis. So basically, we would not be talking about him. I don't think anyone would really remember him outside specialists perhaps in late 19th century american politics if he had
是的，书名叫《伟大密码》（The Great Cryptogram）。是的，这或许能让你对它的学术价值有一个概念。他还写了一本叫《诸神黄昏：火与砾石时代》（Ragnarok, The Age of Fire and Gravel）的书。所以那是《亚特兰蒂斯》的续集。基本上，如果他没有在
not in 1882 published a book called atlantis the antediluvian world so antediluvian before the flood and he very potently mixes these kind you know he's drawing on plato but he's also mixing these kind of very various early modern traditions so he's massively into the idea that essentially civilization as we understand it is seeded by survivors from atlantis yeah his proposition is he's got a number of propositions about atlantis one of which is that the gods and goddesses of the ancient greeks the phoenicians the hindus and the scandinavians were simply the kings queens and heroes of atlantis and that's just intrinsically ridiculous, isn't it? All of them.
1882年出版一本名为《亚特兰蒂斯：大洪水前的世界》的书，我们根本不会谈论他，除了专门研究19世纪末美国政治的学者外，我想没有人会真正记住他。所以这本书是“大洪水之前”。他非常有力地将这些种类……你知道的，他借鉴了柏拉图，但也融合了这些各种各样的早期现代传统：他极其迷信这样一种观点，即我们所理解的文明本质上是由亚特兰蒂斯的幸存者播下的种子。是的，他的主张是——他关于亚特兰蒂斯有一系列主张，其中之一就是古希腊人、腓尼基人、印度人和斯堪的纳维亚人的神灵，其实不过是亚特兰蒂斯的国王、王后和英雄。这本身不是很荒谬吗？所有人都是。
Well, it's the Euhemerist idea. Yeah. This theory put forward by a Greek called Euhemerus, that the gods were mortal kings who had, over the course of the decades and centuries, had come to be elevated into the heavens in people's memories. But I mean, that's a hell of a lot of gods. Yeah, it is. The Scandinavians, the Hindus, the Greeks. I mean, I think what he's doing there is this is an age when people are
好吧，这就是尤赫迈罗主义（Euhemerism）的观点。是的。由一个名叫尤赫迈罗斯的希腊人提出的理论，即神祇其实是凡人君王，他们在几十年和几个世纪的流传中，在人们的记忆中被提升到了天堂。但我的意思是，那可是相当多的神啊。是的，确实如此。斯堪的纳维亚人、印度人、希腊人……我的意思是，我认为他在那里所做的是，这是一个人们对比较神话学越来越感兴趣的时代，人们在起草万神殿的名单，而他在寻找相似之处。我的意思是，你可以看到，你知道的，希腊人、印度人、斯堪的纳维亚人，他们都是印欧人。所以这是另一个非常流行的观点。而他在说，这些不同万神殿之间的相似之处，可以用他们都来自亚特兰蒂斯这一事实来解释。然后他为了好玩，又把不属于印欧人的腓尼基人也塞了进去。他认为有两个地方特别保留了亚特兰蒂斯的原始宗教，那就是埃及和秘鲁。
becoming increasingly interested in kind of comparative mythology and people are drawing up lists of pantheons and he's kind of working out parallels. I mean, you can see, you know, the Greeks, the Hindus, Scandinavians, they're all Indo-Europeans. So that's another idea that is very current. And he's saying that the similarities between these various pantheons are to be explained by the fact that they all came from Atlantis. And then he chucks in the Phoenicians who are not Indo-European just for fun. He argues that there are two places in particular that preserve the original religion of Atlantis and they are Egypt and Peru.
但这两个地方有着不同的宗教，汤姆。好吧。这似乎正是他推理中的漏洞。好吧，你可能会这么说。是的。我认为他的论点是，学者们没有充分认识到它们实际上是多么相似的程度。所以这是另一个主题，那就是写亚特兰蒂斯书籍的人通常都是
But which have different religions, Tom. Well. And that would seem to be the flaw in his reasoning. Well, you may say that. Yeah. I think the argument is that scholars have inadequately appreciated the degree to which they were actually the same. So this is another theme is that people who write about books about Atlantis are often
该学科的自学者，并且对墨守成规的学者怀有深深的蔑视。所以这也是接下来会出现的一点。主流学术机构一直在压制、审查关于埃及和秘鲁宗教的真相。好吧，行吧。他说，在欧洲，青铜时代和铁器时代都起源于来自亚特兰蒂斯的定居者。他认为不仅仅是美洲在被殖民，欧洲也是如此。所以如果
self-educated in the subject and have a deep contempt for hidebound academics. So this is another thing that will be coming up. The mainstream academic establishment is squashing, is censoring the truth about the religions of Egypt and Peru. Okay, fine. He's saying that in Europe, both the Bronze and the Iron Ages, they have their origins in settlers coming from Atlantis. He's arguing that it's not just America that is being colonized, so is Europe. So they
没有来自大西洋的定居者，他们是不可能学会铁器加工或青铜加工的。冶金学不是我的强项，所以我无法对此持怀疑态度。那字母表呢？所以他说，玛雅字母表和腓尼基字母表都来自亚特兰蒂斯。同样的，这俩字母表肯定非常不同吧？我老实说对玛雅字母表一无所知。如果它和腓尼基字母表有任何相似之处，我会非常惊讶的。是的。
wouldn't have learned ironworking or bronzeworking without settlers from the Atlantic. Metallurgy is not my strong point, so I can't be skeptical about that. What about alphabets? So he's saying that both the Mayan and the Phoenician alphabets come from Atlantis. Again, surely very different alphabets, are they? I honestly don't know about the Mayan alphabet. I'd be very surprised if it was anything like the Phoenician alphabets come from Atlantis. Again, surely very different alphabets, are they? I honestly don't know about the Mayan alphabet. I'd be very surprised if it was anything like the Phoenician alphabet. Yeah.
也许如果有任何研究玛雅的专家在听，他们可以指出这在任何程度上是否是一个合理的理论。他认为，基本上在亚特兰蒂斯毁灭之后，少数幸存者乘船逃生，他们被海流带到了美洲、非洲和欧洲。正是这一点解释了唐纳利所说的那种几乎到处都能找到的关于大洪水普遍存在的传说，基本上从太平洋到里海都能找到。
Maybe if there are any specialists in Mayan out there, they could advise on whether this is in any way a plausible theory. And he argues that basically after the destruction of Atlantis, that a few survivors escape on ships, that they are carried across the ocean to both America and to Africa and Europe. And that it's this that explains the kind of universal story of the flood that Donnelly says is to be found pretty much everywhere, basically from the Pacific to the Caspian.
是的。关于大洪水确实存在普遍的传说，对吧？它不完全是普遍的，但我的意思是，这是一个非常普遍的传说。非常普遍。是的。奥卡姆剃刀原理就是，你知道的，人们就是喜欢洪水的想法。是的，我会这么说。
Yeah. There is a universal legend of the flood, isn't there? It's not entirely universal, but I mean, it's a very common one. It's very common. Yeah. Occam's razor is just, you know, people, they're like the idea of floods. Yeah. I would say.
无论如何。所以这是其中的一个方面。然后就是从弗朗西斯·培根那里继承来的“它是一个乌托邦”的观点。这种殖民之所以具有重要意义，是因为唐纳利说，亚特兰蒂斯是人类首次从野蛮和未开化状态跃升至获得文明的地方。我的意思是，这有点像格雷厄姆·汉考克的论点，对吧？这绝对就是格雷厄姆·汉考克的论点。它完全就是格雷厄姆·汉考克的论点。格雷厄姆·汉考克的论点与伊格内修斯·唐纳利唯一的区别在于，唐纳利确实认为亚特兰蒂斯
Anyway. So that's one aspect of it. Then there's the idea that you get from Francis Bacon that it's a utopia. And the reason why this colonization is significant is because Atlantis, Donnelly says, is where basically humans first rose from a state of savagery and barbarism to attain civilization. I mean, this is kind of the Graham Hancock thesis, isn't it? It's absolutely the Graham Hancock thesis. It's totally the Graham Hancock thesis. The only difference between the Graham Hancock thesis and Ignatius Donnelly's is that donnelly does think that the um that atlantis had been in the atlantic
曾经在大西洋中——
yeah so he thinks plato was onto something the plato was right to identify that it was beyond the will of hercules i mean to be fair to him since our only source for the atlantis story is plato and plato is very specific about where it is yeah I mean, he's acknowledging that Plato got that right. So he's obsessed by the idea of different races. Yeah. He's very kind of into that. Well, he's writing in 1882, so that's obviously in the ether, isn't it? He's Irish.
是的，所以他认为柏拉图说得有道理，柏拉图准确地指出它在海格力斯之柱之外。公平地说，既然我们关于亚特兰蒂斯故事的唯一来源就是柏拉图，而柏拉图对它在哪里说得很具体，是的，我的意思是，他承认柏拉图在这点上是对的。所以他痴迷于不同人种的想法。是的，他对这个非常着迷。好吧，他写作的年份是1882年，所以这显然是当时的时代空气，对吧？他是爱尔兰人。
And so he does basically think that the Atlanteans are Irish. Golly, what an amazing coincidence. So he says that the people from Atlantis were red, they had red hair and blue eyes. How can he possibly know? And probably freckles, it wouldn't surprise me. And probably went bright red in the sun. Oh my, I mean...
因此他基本上认为亚特兰蒂斯人是爱尔兰人。天哪，多么惊人的巧合！所以他说来自亚特兰蒂斯的人是红皮肤的，他们有着红头发和蓝眼睛。他怎么可能知道？可能还有雀斑，这我一点也不会惊讶。而且在阳光下可能会变得通红。哦，我的天……
Essentially, they're Irish. This is the thing with all these conspiracy theory explanations, I would have much more time for them if he said, to my amazement, they turned out to be Belgian. Or if he'd sort of said, as an Irishman, it pains me to admit it, but they turned out to be English or something. But to always say, and it happens to be Uppsala or whatever. But there's a tension there because he wants them to be Irish, but at the same time, he wants them to have settled all across Europe and Asia and America. So he's very keen on the idea that
本质上，他们就是爱尔兰人。这就是所有这些阴谋论解释的问题所在，如果他说“令我惊讶的是，他们原来是比利时人”，我会更愿意相信他们。或者如果他说“作为爱尔兰人，我痛苦地承认这一点，但他们原来是英国人”之类的。但总是说——而且恰好是乌普萨拉或其他什么地方。但这其中存在着一种紧张关系，因为他希望他们是爱尔兰人，但与此同时，他又希望他们在欧洲、亚洲和美洲各地都有定居点。所以他非常热衷于这样一种观点：
Atlantis is the original orange point for the Indo-Europeans and for the Semitic peoples, as he describes them. So that's how the Phoenicians and the Greeks and everybody come to get their interest in these ancient peoples and state them for gods. But he also has to explain how they came to be an american how they came to influence america so he describes atlantis as being a bridge of land where the white dark and red races meet so actually although there's a kind of slight element of blowing the trumpet for aryans and specifically irish people he is also the logic of his own argument obliges him to accept that atlantis
亚特兰蒂斯是印欧人和闪米特人（正如他所描述的）的原始发源地。这就是为什么腓尼基人、希腊人和所有其他人都会对这些古代人民产生兴趣并将其尊为神明。但他还必须解释他们是如何来到美洲的，他们是如何影响美洲的。所以他把亚特兰蒂斯描述为白种人、黑种人和红种人交汇的陆地桥梁。所以，尽管其中存在一点为雅利安人特别是爱尔兰人吹喇叭的成分，但他自己论点的逻辑也迫使他接受亚特兰蒂斯
was a place where as he puts it white dark and red races meet well that would match that would match his own political proclivities tom because donnelly was a republican anti-slavery republican yes who had you know been very sort of pro-reconstruction and all that sort of thing so right and so the stereotype of people who are obsessed by mad myths of Atlantis is that they're white supremacists. They're very kind of into the idea that Quetzalcoatl, you know, the story that it's a folk memory of Atlantis, a white man with a beard coming and bringing civilization. That's definitely a part of the mix, but it's not the only part.
是一个——正如他所说——白种人、黑种人和红种人交汇的地方。好吧，这与他自己的政治倾向很吻合，汤姆，因为唐纳利是一个共和党人，一个反奴隶制的共和党人，是的，他（你知道的）非常赞成重建时期（Reconstruction）以及所有这类事情。所以，对吧，所以那些痴迷于亚特兰蒂斯疯狂神话的人的刻板印象是，他们是白人至上主义者。他们非常热衷于这样一种观点：克察尔科亚特尔（Quetzalcoatl），你知道的，那个关于它是亚特兰蒂斯的民间记忆、一个留着胡子的白人前来带去文明的故事。这绝对是其中一部分，但不是全部。
So Donnelly argues that the early Egyptians seemedians seem to have portrayed themselves as as being red so if you think of those kind of you know the paintings egyptians are often portrayed as red and he says that this is because they came from america so the founders of ancient egypt are native american right um and he looks at the great olmec heads in central america and he says that these clearly look african so this olmec civilization was founded by people from settlers colonizers from ultimately from africa so there's a lot of cross fertilization going on according to donnelly he would fit in very well he could be a you know modern museum creator or something tom and he would go down very well well would he uh so we
所以唐纳利认为，早期的埃及人似乎把自己描绘成红皮肤的——如果你想想那种画作，埃及人经常被描绘成红皮肤的——他说这是因为他们来自美洲。所以古埃及的创始人是美洲原住民，对吧？嗯，他看着中美洲巨大的奥尔梅克巨石头像，说这些头像明显看起来是非洲人，所以这个奥尔梅克文明是由来自非洲的定居者、殖民者建立的。所以根据唐纳利的说法，其中存在着大量的文化交融。他非常适合——他可以成为一个现代博物馆的策展人或类似的角色，汤姆，而且他会很受欢迎。好吧，他会吗？所以我们
will come to this perhaps in part two, because I think we should call a halt here. When we come back, we'll have a look at how this idea of Atlantis as the antediluvian civilization, how it got kind of recalibrated in the 20th century in often very dark ways. But before I go, I will read a comment by a French scholar, Thomas Henri Martin, in his studies on Plato's Timaeus, which he published in 1841, with his perspective on all this. Many scholars, he wrote, setting sail in quest of Atlantis with a more or less heavy cargo of erudition, but without any compass except their imagination and caprice, have voyaged at random. And where have they landed? In Africa, in America, in Australia, in Spitsbergen, in Sweden, in Sardinia, in Palestine, in Athens, in Persia, and in Ceylon, they say.
或许会在第二部分讨论这个问题，因为我认为我们应该在这里暂停一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看亚特兰蒂斯作为大洪水前文明的这种概念，在20世纪是如何以通常非常黑暗的方式被重新校准的。但在我离开之前，我要读一位法国学者托马斯·亨利·马丁（Thomas Henri Martin）在他1841年出版的《柏拉图〈蒂迈欧篇〉研究》中对这一切的看法。他写道：“许多学者为了寻找亚特兰蒂斯而扬帆起航，船上装载着或多或少沉重的博学货物，却没有罗盘，只有想象力和突发奇想，结果在海上盲目航行。他们最后在什么地方登陆了？他们说，是在非洲、美洲、澳大利亚、斯匹次卑尔根、瑞典、撒丁岛、巴勒斯坦、雅典、波斯和锡兰。”
That's like a list of Graham Hancock's locations, Tom. C'est vrai. Okay, we'll see you after the break for more Atlantis. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这听起来就像格雷厄姆·汉考克去过的地方清单，汤姆。千真万确（C'est vrai）。好吧，我们休息后见，继续聊亚特兰蒂斯。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史余音》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, we've been talking Atlantis, we talked about Plato, we talked about Gomara, the biography of Cortes, we talked about Francis Bacon, and now, Tom,
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余音》。现在，我们一直在谈论亚特兰蒂斯，我们谈到了柏拉图，我们谈到了科尔特斯的传记作者戈马拉，我们谈到了弗朗西斯·培根，现在，汤姆，
I believe we're about to talk about the Nazis. Is that correct? Well, Dominic, as you will know, one of the kind of organizations that fed into the Nazis was the Thule Society. Yeah, yeah. Thule. We talked about them a lot. They were very runish. They were interested in swastikas and kind of esoteric stuff in Bavaria, weren't they? Yeah.
我相信我们快要谈到纳粹了。是这样吗？好吧，多米尼克，正如你所知，汇入纳粹的组织之一就是图勒协会（Thule Society）。对，对。图勒。我们讨论过他们很多次。他们非常迷恋符文（runes），对巴伐利亚的卐字和某种秘契主义（esoteric stuff）很感兴趣，对吧？是的。
In the late 1910s early 1920s so thule was the um it was the island that lay up furthest north ultima thule the romans called it could that not that's iceland is it is that iceland that's the thinking been variously been thought to be britain or shetland or iceland or greenland or america or whatever but not atlantis it comes to be equated with Atlantis by very radical German nationalists who, drawing on Donnelly, come to see it as the homeland of the Aryans, the Indo-Europeans. And obviously they have the problem that if it's out in the Atlantic, that's no good. They need it to be somewhere nearer to Germany. And so they start to develop basically two mad ideas.
在1910年代末到1920年代初，所以图勒是那个最靠北的岛屿——罗马人称之为“极北之地”（Ultima Thule）。难道那不是——那是冰岛吗？大家对此有不同的看法，有人认为是英国，或者是设得兰群岛，或者是冰岛、格陵兰岛、美洲等等，但绝不是亚特兰蒂斯。它后来被一些激进的德国民族主义者等同于亚特兰蒂斯，他们借鉴了唐纳利的想法，将其视为雅利安人、印欧人的祖国。显然，他们遇到了一个问题：如果它在大西洋中，那就没用了。他们需要它在离德国更近一点的地方。于是他们开始提出两个疯狂的想法。
The first is that essentially it was in the North Sea. So whether this is a kind of echo of Doggerland or whatever, I don't know. They're kind of into that idea. And the other is that Donnelly had hyped up the Atlanteans as having super advanced technology. But for the Nazis, the technology is off the scale. And actually, what they're doing there, they're drawing on the work of another hugely influential American on this myth, a guy called Edgar Cayce,
第一个是，本质上它在北海。所以这是否是多格兰（Doggerland）或某种东西的回响，我不知道。他们对这种想法很感兴趣。另一个是，唐纳利曾大肆吹捧亚特兰蒂斯人拥有超级先进的技术。但对纳粹来说，这种技术简直超出了图表。实际上，他们在那里借鉴了另一个对这个神话产生巨大影响的美国人的作品，一个名叫埃德加·凯西（Edgar Cayce）的人，
who was known as the sleeping prophet, who was a guy who, whenever he went to sleep, he would have visions. So yeah, it's a clairvoyant. Yeah, well, this goes all the way back to when he was doing school and he couldn't couldn't you know he hadn't done his spellings properly and so his father walloped him and he ran to bed sobbing and then an angel came in the
他被称为“沉睡的先知”，是一个每当他睡着就会有幻象的人。所以，是的，他是一个千里眼。是的，这一切都可以追溯到他上学的时候，当时他拼写没做好——你知道的，他没把拼写拼好，于是他父亲狠狠地揍了他一顿，他哭着跑到床上去，然后一个天使在夜里
night and taught him his spelling and when he woke up he could do it perfectly and this angel kept appearing to him over the course of his life and he came up with all kinds of well kind of mad stuff um diagnose you in your sleep i I'm just reading it now. Yeah. He was struck in the coccyx during a school football game, began to act strangely. While asleep, he diagnosed his own injury and prescribed a cure, which worked.
来到并教导他拼写，当他醒来时，他就能完美地拼写了。这个天使在他的一生中一直出现在他面前，他提出了各种各样……嗯，有点疯狂的东西，比如在睡梦中为你诊断。我刚刚在读这个。是的。他在学校的一次橄榄球比赛中尾骨受了伤，开始表现得很奇怪。在睡梦中，他诊断了自己的伤情并开出了一个疗方，而且还真的治好了。
And since then, whenever you went to see him, when something was wrong with you, he would go to sleep. Right. And get a vision of what of what to do well and so his his visions kind of went on quite a long way from how to stop sports injuries a bit like um donnelly i mean a bit like everybody he's obsessed by races so he's obsessed with the idea that there are different races born at different times so there's the white the black the brown the yellow the red races and he's obsessed by Atlantis. And he says,
自那以后，每当你去看他，当你身体不舒服时，他就会睡着。对的。然后对该怎么做产生一种幻视。所以他的幻视延伸得很远，从如何阻止运动伤害，有点像——嗯，唐利——我的意思是，有点像所有人一样，他痴迷于人种，所以他痴迷于这样的观点：不同的人种诞生于不同的时期，所以有白种人、黑人、棕色人种、黄色人种、红色人种，而且他痴迷于亚特兰蒂斯。他说，
again, intriguingly, that the Atlanteans were the red races. So they were the Native Americans. And he says as well, that they'd solved the energy crisis by developing crystals. And that these crystals had sunk beneath the waves when Atlantis plunged, got destroyed. And that this is what explains the Bermuda Triangle. This is a popular theory. That's where the crystals are. Yes, exactly. Okay.
同样耐人寻味的是，亚特兰蒂斯人是红种人。所以他们就是美洲原住民。他还说，他们通过开发水晶解决了能源危机。当亚特兰蒂斯沉没、被毁时，这些水晶沉入了波涛之下。这就是百慕大三角的解释。这是一个很流行的理论。水晶就在那里。是的，没错。好的。
So that's why ships vanish and planes and things. And Cayce also predicted that these crystals would be rediscovered by the United States in 1958. Golly, that's precise. Were they? Doesn't seem so. He had a lot of very big name celebrity clients. Yeah, he did. Because of his dream vision.
所以这就是为什么船只和飞机等会消失。凯西还预测，美国将在1958年重新发现这些水晶。天哪，这真精确。他们找到了吗？似乎并没有。他有很多很大牌的名人客户。是的，他确实有。因为他的梦境幻视。
So Woodrow Wilson was one. And very much not a friend of the rest of his history, top murderer Thomas Edison. Yes. That's one. So we discussed Edison murdering Louis Leprince in a previous episode. But a thing that had not previously
伍德罗·威尔逊就是其中之一。还有一个绝对不是他这段历史的朋友，顶级杀手托马斯·爱迪生。是的。就是这个。我们在上一集里讨论过爱迪生谋杀路易·勒普兰斯的事。但之前我没有想到的一点是，
occurred to me was that he could have case might have been involved with that in some mysterious way well there's a whole novel waiting to be written there isn't there because even though case was then a child it was when he was a child that he was being visited by angels and doing a lot of his coccyx kind of diagnosing work i think it's coccyx dominic it is coccyx yeah it is coccyx it's just um i'm not i'm not really i'm not a medical man no no you've never never attended otherwise no unlike edgar case actually yeah one of the things we don't have yeah anyway so all this kind of stuff about crystals superpowers all this kind of thing fuses in germany before and after the first world war with ideas that
凯西可能以某种神秘的方式参与其中。好吧，那里有一部完整的小说等着被写出来，不是吗？因为尽管凯西当时还是个孩子，正是在他还是个孩子的时候，他得到了天使的造访，并做了很多类似尾骨的诊断工作。多米尼克，我觉得那是尾骨。是的，多米尼克，确实是尾骨。没错，就是尾骨。这只是……我不是，我真的不是，我不是个医务人员。不，不，你从来没有，从来没有从事过别的职业。不，其实跟埃德加·凯西不一样，对吧。我们没有的其中一件事，是的。不管怎样，所有关于水晶、超能力这类的事情，在第一次世界大战前后的德国与以下观点融合在了一起：
atlantis might actually have been in the north Sea. And although Hitler himself, to give Hitler credit, not a phrase you often hear on, but to give him credit, he thought this was all mad. So he had no time for Atlantis being the homeland of the German people. But Rudolf Hess was very into it. Alfred Rosenberg was very into it. Himmler, inevitably, I mean, he was all over it. And during the war, he was very into it uh alfred rosenberg was very into it himmler inevitably i mean he was all over it and during the war he was very disappointed that the state of war meant that he couldn't launch um deep sea explorations in the north sea in the north sea so i think had they won the war he would have it would have been great for for the archaeology of doggerland yes obviously it would have been terrible in all kinds of other ways. It's important that you point that out, Tom.
亚特兰蒂斯实际上可能在北海。尽管希特勒本人——为了给希特勒一点赞赏，这不是你经常听到的短语——但为了给他一点赞赏，他认为这一切都是疯狂的。所以他根本不认为亚特兰蒂斯是德国人民的故乡。但鲁道夫·赫斯非常热衷于此。阿尔弗雷德·罗森贝格非常热衷于此。希姆莱，不可避免地，我的意思是，他对此全力以赴。在战争期间，他对此非常热衷……嗯，阿尔弗雷德·罗森贝格非常热衷于此，希姆莱，不可避免地，我的意思是，他对此全力以赴。在战争期间，他对战争状态意味着他无法在北海发动深海探测而感到非常失望……在北海。所以我想，如果他们赢了这场战争，他对多格兰的考古学来说将是太棒了。是的，显然在各种其他方面这会是可怕的。指出这一点很重要，汤姆。
But if you're a fan of archaeology of the Doggerland, Himmler would have ploughed billions of Reichsmarks into excavating it. This is very Man in the High Castle, though, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, have you seen that? That's the adaptation of the Philip K. Dick novel. I mean, I'm surprised they didn't work this in. But that tells you about Atlantis,
但如果你是多格兰考古学的粉丝，希姆莱会投入数十亿帝国马克来发掘它。不过，这非常像《高堡奇人》，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，你看过那个吗？那是对菲利普·K·迪克小说的改编。我的意思是，我很惊讶他们没有把这个融合进去。但这告诉了你关于亚特兰蒂斯的什么，
doesn't it? It's to do with crystals, clairvoyance, sort of strange mythological science, which is all in the air in the late 19th, early 20th century. Yeah. But the Nazis, obviously, having none of this idea that you get to make a case that the Atlanteans were Native Americans, or that you get in Ignatius Donnelly, that it's a melting pot for red, white, and black races. I mean, they're very into races, but there's only one race in Atlantis, and that's the white race, and specifically the Aryan race. And so that makes the whole Atlantis story suddenly seem incredibly sinister in the wake of the war. And so that means that in the wake of the Second World War, the Atlantis myth,
不是吗？它与水晶、透视力、某种奇怪的神话科学有关，这些在19世纪末、20世纪初都充斥在空气中。是的。但纳粹显然不接受“亚特兰蒂斯人是美洲原住民”这种观点，也不接受伊格纳蒂斯·唐利的观点，即它是红、白、黑人种的熔炉。我的意思是，他们非常热衷于人种，但亚特兰蒂斯只有一个人种，那就是白种人，特别是雅利安人。因此，在战后，这使得整个亚特兰蒂斯的故事突然显得极其险恶。这意味着在第二次世界大战之后，亚特兰蒂斯神话——
although its popularity remains, I mean, there are endless kind of books being written about it. I'm sure you probably read them as a child. I mean, I was fascinated. Oh, God, I was fascinated by Atlantis when I was about 10 or something. Yeah, absolutely. And it's inspired all kinds, you know, Man from Atlantis we mentioned and all kinds of things like that. Yeah. Often for scholars, it seems quite sinister.
尽管它的热度依然存在，我的意思是，有源源不断关于它的书被写出来。我确信你小时候可能读过它们。我的意思是，我曾为之着迷。哦，天哪，当我10岁左右的时候，我为亚特兰蒂斯着迷。是的，绝对的。它激发了各种各样的灵感，你知道的，我们提到的《来自亚特兰蒂斯的男子》以及各种类似的东西。是的。对于学者来说，它通常显得相当险恶。
The story seems quite sinister because they're aware of where it led. And the idea that you can be interested in Atlantis and then suddenly become a white supremacist becomes quite an important idea. But I think the inherent fascination of the myth is such that even academics, even archaeologists, even very distinguished scholars have been unable to resist its allure. And if the kind of the Nazi reinterpretation of Atlantis is the most notorious, perhaps the most convincing explanation is one that also emerged in the early years of the 20th century, when Arthur Evans, the English archaeologist, discovered what he came to call Minoan civilization. So an ancient
这个故事显得相当险恶，因为他们知道它通向何方。而且“你可以对亚特兰蒂斯感兴趣，然后突然变成一个白人至上主义者”这种想法，变成了一个相当重要的概念。但我认为，神话本身固有的魅力是如此之大，以至于连学者、考古学家、甚至非常杰出的学者都无法抗拒它的诱惑。如果说纳粹对亚特兰蒂斯的重新诠释最为臭名昭著，那么也许最令人信服的解释是也在20世纪初出现的那一个，当时英国考古学家阿瑟·埃文斯发现了后来被称为米诺斯文明的事物。因此是一个古代
civilization on Crete that had not previously been suspected. People, I'm sure, you know, been on holiday to Crete, been to Knossos, all that kind of stuff. I was about to say, he's the guy who basically created Knossos and claimed it was authentic. Is that right? Yeah, that's right. I've got a book on Knossos. It's kind of the opening line is to the effect of the Bronze Age palace of Knossos is one of the most striking modernist buildings. So he basically invents it. But there's this idea that it's a highly sophisticated civilization, lots of ships, that it establishes what Thucydides called a thalassocracy under King Minos.
克里特岛上以前不为人知的文明。我确信人们，你知道的，去过克里特岛度假，去过克诺索斯，所有这些东西。我正要说，他就是那个基本上创建了克诺索斯并声称它是真实的人。是这样吗？是的，没错。我有一本关于克诺索斯的书。它的开篇大致意思是，克诺索斯的青铜时代宫殿是最引人注目的现代主义建筑之一。所以他基本上是凭空捏造的。但有这样一种观点：这是一个高度复杂的文明，有很多船只，它建立了修昔底德在米诺斯国王统治下所称的海上霸权。
So an empire of the sea, which is all very Atlantis. And there are lots of frescoes of people jumping bulls that were found. And the Atlanteans are supposed to have had a particular relationship with the bull because Poseidon, who is the forefather of the Atlantean kings, his sacred animal was the bull. So it all kind of seems to connect together. And then one of the archaeologists who proposes this a greek archaeologist called spirit on marinatos he then goes to an island called santorini which in ancient times was called thera which there had clearly been an absolutely massive volcanic explosion there um so much so that the kind of the middle of the island is just
因此，这是一个海上帝国，这非常像亚特兰蒂斯。那里发现了许多人跳牛的壁画。亚特兰蒂斯人本应与公牛有着特殊的关系，因为波塞冬是亚特兰蒂斯国王的祖先，他的神圣动物就是公牛。所以这一切似乎都联系在了一起。然后，提出这一理论的一位考古学家，一位名叫斯皮里顿·马里纳托斯的希腊考古学家，随后前往一个名为圣托里尼的岛屿，在古代被称为锡拉，那里显然发生过一次绝对巨大的火山爆炸——以至于岛屿的中央简直
gone it's a kind of circle around the bay. It's the huge caldera, isn't it? The crater. Yeah. And he excavates a site there called Akrotiri. And again, he finds all kinds of freezes of teeming harbors, ships, all this kind of stuff. And he thinks this is very, very Atlantis. And this is the kind of academically acceptable version of the myth but this is so well known
消失了，在海湾周围形成了一个圈。那是巨大的破火山口，不是吗？那个火山口。是的。他在那里发掘了一个名为阿克罗蒂里的遗址。同样，他发现了各种各样挤满港口、船只的壁画，所有这些东西。他认为这非常非常像亚特兰蒂斯。这就是神话中学术上可以接受的版本，但这非常广为人知，
this is what you see in the rough guide to yeah Santorini or you I mean to be honest with you Tom before we did this I had vaguely as a complete and utter outsider I just vaguely assumed that you were going to say it's generally now agreed that Atlantis is Santorini so I mean you will see endless documentaries about it yeah you will get kind of mad documentaries where it's generally now agreed that atlantis is santorini so i mean you will see endless documentaries about it yeah you will get kind of mad documentaries where it's aliens on the history channel yeah but you will get this on channel 4 and bbc2 yeah this is classic bbc2 material yeah here's a story about theory which is the real atlantis i think basically the issue the problem that you have with all the other theories are just as present with this so the obvious one is plato's very specific atlantis was in the atlantic crete or thera or wherever is it it's
这就是你在《粗略指南》中看到的……是的，圣托里尼，或者说，老实说，汤姆，在我们做这个之前，作为一个完全的外行，我只是隐约以为你会说，现在人们普遍认为亚特兰蒂斯就是圣托里尼。所以我的意思是，你会看到无数关于它的纪录片。是的，你会看到那种疯狂的纪录片，其中普遍认为亚特兰蒂斯是圣托里尼。所以我的意思是，你会看到无数关于它的纪录片。是的，你会看到历史频道的疯狂纪录片，关于外星人的，是的。但你会在第四频道和BBC二台看到这个。是的，这是经典的BBC二台题材。是的，这里有一个关于锡拉的故事，它才是真正的亚特兰蒂斯。我认为基本上所有其他理论面临的问题，在这个理论中也同样存在。最明显的一个是柏拉图非常具体的说法：亚特兰蒂斯在大西洋，而克里特或锡拉无论在哪里，它们可
not in the atlantic yeah so that's a major problem in this atlantis is is destroyed by a volcano but there's no mention of a volcano in plato's account it sinks beneath the sea uh he might have just forgotten the volcano and talked about the tsunami that followed. Right, so he forgot. So there's no hint of this in any account or indeed in any myth. So we do have myths about Crete. You know, we have
不在大西洋。是的，这是个大问题。这个亚特兰蒂斯被火山摧毁了，但柏拉图的叙述中根本没有提到火山。它沉入了海底。他可能只是忘记了火山，而谈论了随之而来的海啸。对的，所以他忘了。所以在任何叙述中，甚至在任何神话中，都没有这方面的暗示。所以我们确实有关于克里特岛的神话。你知道，我们有
Theseus, we have the Minotaur, we have King Minos, which gives his name to this culture. But there's no hint at all of Atlantis in any of these myths. Well, I mean, matching it to Plato is mad if we accept your premise that plato was writing about a political metaphor well we have no evidence at all for anything that links the destruction of of um thera whenever it is when is it kind of middle middle of the second millennium to the time of plato which is kind of thousand years and more after it yeah how is that passed down? We have no trace of how it was passed down whatsoever until suddenly
忒修斯，我们有米诺陶洛斯，我们有米诺斯国王，这个文化就是以他的名字命名的。但在所有这些神话中，根本没有一点关于亚特兰蒂斯的暗示。好吧，我的意思是，如果接受你关于柏拉图是在写政治隐喻的前提，那么把它和柏拉图对上号是疯狂的。好吧，我们根本没有任何证据能将……毁灭……嗯，锡拉，无论它是什么时候，什么时候？——公元前第二个千年中期，与柏拉图的时代联系起来，柏拉图的时代比那晚了一千年甚至更久。是的，这怎么流传下来的？我们根本没有任何关于它是如何流传下来的痕迹，直到突然
it becomes fully formed in Plato's account. Right. There's not some other corpus of legends. Right. And in Plato, Plato himself says, or the various actors within his dialogue say, nobody's heard of this. And Critias, who is telling it, has to come up with a very kind of highfalutin account of how it is that he's heard it when nobody else has heard it that's the whole point nobody knows about this story so how does plato know about it yeah in the story atlantis is 11 500 years old i don't think crete is okay neither crete nor santorini remotely resemble plato's description of it okay well you mean you mean the archaeological findings don't yeah there's no canals no kind you know, walls going around it in Minas Tirith style. No elephants.
它在柏拉图的叙述中完全成形。对的。并没有其他的一套传说。对的。而且在柏拉图那里，柏拉图自己说，或者他对话中的各个角色说，没有人听说过这个。而讲述它的克里提亚斯，不得不拿出一个非常高调的说法，解释他是如何听说这个别人都没听说过的事情的。这正是重点所在，没有人知道这个故事，所以柏拉图是怎么知道的？是的。在故事中，亚特兰蒂斯有一万五千年的历史。我不认为克里特岛有。好吧，无论是克里特岛还是圣托里尼，都与柏拉图的描述完全不相符。好吧，你的意思是考古发现不符。是的，没有运河，没有米纳斯提力斯风格的环城墙。没有大象。
Well, to be fair, the elephants might not have been indigenous. They might have been brought by traders or tributes. I've just, you know. Basically, so people call this, you know, pseudo-history, pseudo-archaeology, all the Atlantis stuff. This is posh pseudo-archaeology. Right. history pseudo archaeology all the atlantis stuff this is posh pseudo archaeology right in the way that the cathars having been a secret dualist cult is kind of posh right pseudo history okay fair enough but i think it's kind of testimony to the inherent fascination of it and i think that it
好吧，公平地说，大象可能不是土生土长的。它们可能是由商人和朝贡者带来的。我只是……你知道的。基本上，人们把所有这些亚特兰蒂斯的东西称为伪历史、伪考古学。这是高级伪考古学。对的。历史、伪考古学，所有这些亚特兰蒂斯的东西。这是高级伪考古学。对的。就像卡特里派曾是一个秘密二元论邪教一样，这有点像高级的伪历史。好吧，很有道理。但我认为这证明了它固有的魅力，而且我认为它
it suggests how even archaeologists you know can succumb to the romance of the account yeah and it's that that makes the Graham Hancock series and his book so interesting, I think. So Graham Hancock is basically, his background, he was a journalist, I think the economist in East Africa. He wrote a lot about the politics of aid, things like that. Then because he was in Ethiopia, he got obsessed by the story that the Ark of the Covenant is kept in a church in Ethiopia. And then from that, he moved on to writing about ancient Egypt, the idea that the pyramids at Giza map onto the stars that you see in the constellation of Orion.
表明了即使是考古学家，你知道的，也会屈服于这种叙事的浪漫色彩。是的，正是这一点让格雷姆·汉考克的系列节目和他的书如此有趣，我认为。所以格雷姆·汉考克基本上，他的背景是记者，我记得是东非的《经济学人》杂志记者。他写了很多关于援助政治之类的文章。然后因为他在埃塞俄比亚，他痴迷于“约柜保存在埃塞俄比亚一座教堂里”的故事。从那以后，他转向了写作古埃及，认为吉萨的金字塔对应着猎户座星座中看到的星星。
And it kind of spiraled out from that. I think in your life, you're allowed to come up with one theory of this kind. But if you come up with more than one, it discredits the... Well, like Donnelly with Shakespeare was bacon. Yeah, exactly. I mean, I've watched Ancient Apocalypse. You've watched it all through, haven't you? I've watched it all through.
事情就是从那时起滚雪球般发展起来的。我认为在人的一生中，你被允许提出一个这种类型的理论。但如果你提出了一个以上，就会破坏……好吧，就像唐利认为莎士比亚其实是培根一样。是的，完全同意。我的意思是，我看了《远古启示录》。你把它从头到尾都看完了，对吧？我从头到尾都看完了。
And in that, I mean, maybe he's concealing it. Maybe secretly he's a Nazi. I don't know. Maybe he's secretly a white supremacist. But based on those documentaries, the whole thing is about environmentalism. Right. You know, he's essentially saying that, as far as I could tell, that unless we stop using electricity, we're going to get wiped out by a comet no one will be
在那里，我的意思是，也许他在隐瞒。也许他秘密是个纳粹。我不知道。也许他秘密是个白人至上主义者。但根据那些纪录片，整件事都关乎环保主义。对的。你知道，他基本上是在说，据我所能看出的，除非我们停止使用电力，否则我们将被彗星消灭，没有人会
able to watch his programs unfortunately that happens he's um hostile to european colonialism he talks refers to 19th century land grabs so as far as i can tell he's not a white supremacist right this is not a program for him to enjoy but this is very much the tenor of the criticism that archaeologists aim at him. So the idea is that this is a gateway drug that will lead you to white supremacy. Yeah, I've read that essay on the Guardian website, Tom, saying Graham Hancock is leading people into, you know, QAnon or something. Yes. And I think that's because the uses that the Nazis put this story to hang so heavily, that it's tainted the whole enterprise. And I think also it's the idea that there's an anxiety
能够观看他的节目。不幸的是，事情就是这样。他对欧洲殖民主义持敌对态度，他谈到了19世纪的土地掠夺。所以据我所能看出的，他不是一个白人至上主义者。对的。这不是一个让他享受的节目。但考古学家针对他的批评基调正是如此。因此，这个想法是，这是一个会引向白人至上主义的入门毒品。是的，汤姆，我在卫报网站上读过那篇评论，说格雷姆·汉考克正在引导人们走向“匿名者Q”之类的东西。是的。我认为这是因为纳粹对这个故事的利用影响太深远了，以至于玷污了整个事业。而且我认为这也是一种焦虑，
about the idea that, say, American cultures, Native American cultures derived from new settlers, from colonists from the East. There's an obvious kind of anxiety about that yeah but i mean to be fair to case and to donnelly and to people who who hancock is clearly drawing this stuff deriving this stuff from yeah you know as we've seen it's it's slightly more complicated than saying that the atlanteans were white people i mean there is a kind of element of that certainly the nazis drew on but it's not exclusively that yeah you know case is saying that the atlanteans were native americans they were they were they were the red race yes and donnelly is saying that it's a kind of melting pot for american european african peoples so and graham hancock is all over i mean he's all over the world he's going to indonesia or wherever and
担心美洲文化、美洲原住民文化源自新定居者、源自东方的殖民者。这有一种显而易见的焦虑。是的，但我的意思是，公平对待凯西、唐利以及汉考克显然在从中汲取素材的人——是的，你知道的，正如我们所看到的，这比简单地说亚特兰蒂斯人是白人要稍微复杂一些。我的意思是，这确实包含某种成分，纳粹当然借鉴了这一点，但并非完全如此。是的，你知道，凯西说亚特兰蒂斯人是美洲原住民，他们是红种人。是的，而唐利说，它是美洲、欧洲、非洲人民的熔炉。所以，格雷姆·汉考克涉猎广泛，我的意思是，他走遍世界各地，去印度尼西亚或其他地方，
saying there are traces of superior civilizations here yeah so it's not it's all eurocentric yeah i think i mean i think it's not i mean Eurocentric. Yeah, I think, I mean, I think it's not. I mean, I think he's saying that European civilization derives as much from the Atlanteans as does American civilization. Yeah. So yeah, so essentially his argument is that Ignatius Donnelly won,
说这里有更高等文明的痕迹。所以，这并不是纯粹欧洲中心主义的。是的，我认为，我的意思是，我认为不是。我的意思是，我认为他是在说，欧洲文明和美洲文明一样，同样源自亚特兰蒂斯人。是的。所以，是的，所以他的论点基本上是伊格纳蒂斯·唐利赢了，
that there was a great catastrophe, a highly advanced civilization was wiped out, and that these people then went around and kind of seeded civilization around the world. And archaeologists obviously absolutely hate this. And I think that one of the reasons why they like to cast Graham Hancock as a kind of gateway drug to white supremacy is that it gives them a kind of Indiana Jones vibe.
曾有过一场大灾难，一个高度先进的文明被消灭了，然后这些人四处游历，在世界各地播撒文明的种子。考古学家显然绝对痛恨这一点。我认为他们之所以喜欢把格雷姆·汉考克塑造成通往白人至上主义的“入门毒品”的原因之一，是这赋予了他们一种印第安纳·琼斯式的氛围。
Oh, right, I see. They're taking on Nazis. Right. They are fighting the good fight against the forces of evil. Yes. So rather than excavatingating pots they're fighting fascism right or fighting fascism by excavating pots exactly so but obviously what is really infuriating is the fact that graham hancock is clearly spectacularly wrong okay and you can absolutely see it's infuriating i just thought you're gonna say spectacular say spectacularly rich. Yes, well, he's wrong and rich. And so how infuriating it must be, you know,
哦，对了，我明白了。他们在对抗纳粹。对的。他们在为正义事业而战，对抗邪恶势力。是的。所以他们不是在发掘陶罐，而是在抗击法西斯主义。对的。或者说通过发掘陶罐来抗击法西斯主义。完全正确。但是，显然真正令人愤怒的是，格雷姆·汉考克显然错得离谱。好吧，你绝对可以看出这很令人愤怒。我刚才以为你要说“错得”极其富有。是的，好吧，他又错又有钱。所以这一定有多令人愤怒啊，你知道的，
to have spent decades mastering the chronology of the late Ice Age and, you know, having a kind of incredibly detailed knowledge of all these various excavation sites. Phoenician pottery. Yes, and then this guy pops up, has a 10-part series on Netflix, you know, million-selling book. And Graham Hancock is very, very abusive about them.
花了幾十年时间掌握晚冰河时期的年代学，你知道的，对所有这些不同的发掘遗址有着极其详细的了解。腓尼基陶器。是的，然后这家伙突然冒出来，在网飞上拍了一个十集的系列节目，你知道的，百万畅销书。而且格雷姆·汉考克对他们非常恶劣。
So he's very into the idea that there's, basically, it's big archaeology. That big archaeology has discovered the truth, but it's concealing it from everybody. Presumably, he would say, listen to this, that we are the tools of big archaeology, would he? Yes but tom he would okay well let's let's see if that doesn't happen because i will stick up for him tom is he wrong i mean you you blithely say graham hancock is incredibly wrong as well as incredibly rich but but what what persuades you that he is so wrong
所以他非常热衷于这样一种观点，基本上就是“大考古学”。大考古学已经发现了真相，但它在向所有人隐瞒。据我推测，他会说，听着，我们就是大考古学的工具，他会这么说吗？是的。但汤姆，他会……好吧，让我们看看这会不会发生，因为我会为他辩护的，汤姆。他错了吗？我的意思是，你轻率地说格雷姆·汉考克错得离谱，而且极其富有，但是，但是是什么说服了你他错得那么离谱，
you know convince me well i think the overwhelming evidence for it is that we have no evidence right i mean there is absolutely zero evidence yeah for any of this okay apart from the atlantis story which is the initial inspiration for it and then hancock is going around the world trying to kind of bundle up any any hint of myth that suggests that um that might corroborate it so for instance he's citing zoroastrian myth, which isn't written down for centuries and centuries and centuries after, millennia after. It's as improbable as the idea that Plato is actually transcribing an actual story. Yeah, which seems, when you read the Plato thing, it actually seems blindingly obvious that he's not giving you.
说服我吧。好吧，我认为最有力的证据是，我们根本没有证据。对的。我的意思是，绝对零证据。是的，除了最初激发灵感的亚特兰蒂斯故事之外，没有任何证据。然后汉考克环游世界，试图拼凑出任何暗示可以佐证它的神话线索。例如，他引用了琐罗亚斯德教的神话，而这在事发几个世纪、几千年之后才被写下来。这和柏拉图实际上是在抄写一个真实故事的想法一样不可信。是的，当阅读柏拉图的内容时，这似乎好得让人眼花缭乱，他根本不是在给你提供……
Yeah. And the thing is that when he goes to these sites which he claims are were actually built by people from atlantis there's lots of evidence for say the hunter-gatherers who were living there yeah lots of archaeological evidence but there's absolutely no archaeological evidence at all that they were highly superior and sophisticated the iphones are nowhere to be seen there are no iphones at all there are no crystals i mean there's nothing yeah so there's there's an absolute absence of any hard archaeological evidence. And I think that the idea that big archaeology has been secretly hiding it is disproven by the fact that actually the most intriguing site that he visits in the course of his expedition, Göbekli Tepe, which is this site in Turkey, which dates back you know a very very long way um and it it is really old and really fascinating and it's kind of from the end of the ice age the beginning of
问题是，当他去到他声称是由亚特兰蒂斯人建造的这些遗址时，有很多证据表明那里生活着狩猎采集者。是的，有大量的考古证据，但绝对没有任何考古证据表明他们曾经高度优越和精致。苹果手机踪迹全无。根本没有苹果手机，也没有水晶，什么都没有。是的。所以绝对没有任何确凿的考古证据。我认为“大考古学一直在秘密隐瞒它”这种观点已经被事实打破：事实上，他在探险过程中访问过的最引人入胜的遗址——哥贝克力石殿，这个位于土耳其的遗址，其历史可以追溯到非常非常久远的过去，而且它真的很古老，非常迷人，它来自冰河时代末期、
the holocene archaeologists how does he know about he knows about it because archaeologists found it yeah and excavated they're not covering it up they're not covering it up um and and his technique is he will go there and he'll have some hapless you know curator or somebody who's in charge of the site who will kind of give the lowdown on it and then she'll be cut and suddenly there'll be some bloke usually with a beard who will pop up and he'll be all about the crystals star patterns and things like that right and they'll be cut together so it looks as though the pair of them are telling the same story, which of course they aren't. So right from the beginning, Graham
全新世初期。考古学家是怎么知道它的？考古学家发现的它，是的。并进行了发掘。他们没有掩盖它。他们没有掩盖它。而且他的技巧是，他会去那里，找一个倒霉的馆长或者某个负责遗址的人，让他提供内幕消息，然后镜头一切，通常会冒出一个留着胡子的人，他满口都是水晶、星象图案之类的话。对的。然后他们剪辑在一起，看起来好像这两人在讲同一个故事，当然他们并不是。所以从一开始，格雷姆
Hancock has been into this idea that the people who escaped from this catastrophe were obsessed by the stars and that there are lessons to be found in the stars that are imprinted in various monuments, say the pyramids and so on. And he's all over Gobekli Tepe. And there's particularly, there's a pillar 43, it's called the Vulture Stone at Gobekli Tepe, where he reads all kinds of messages about what the procession of the equinox, which is when the earth wobbles on its axis and where the sun rises at the spring equinox kind of moves westward gradually over the course of millennia. And then it kind of moves back. And this happens kind of over the course of, don't know 25 000
汉考克就迷恋这样一种观点：从这场灾难中逃脱出来的人对星象着迷，星象中蕴含着各种古迹（如金字塔等）上铭刻的教训。他对哥贝克力石殿了解得很透彻。特别是，那里有一根43号柱子，被称为哥贝克力石殿的秃鹫石，他在上面解读出关于岁差的各种信息。岁差是指地球在自转轴上摇晃，春分点时太阳升起的位置在几个世纪的进程中逐渐向西移动。然后它又移回来。这大约在……
odd years and that this is written into all these ancient monuments but there's a glaring problem with that which is that it depends on there being an idea of a zodiac because he's kind of tracing it through the idea of the zodiac and he's he's identifying various images on this vulture stone as being portrayals of of the constellations that form the Zodiac. But these constellations originate with Babylon. So there's no way that they didn't know the Babylonian Zodiac. I mean, it's kind of really obvious. So all of those reasons, I think, suggest that it's improbable.
不知道，两万五千年左右的时间里发生，并且这被写进了所有这些古代古迹中。但这里有一个显而易见的问题：这依赖于存在一个黄道带的概念，因为他是通过黄道带的概念来追溯它的，并且他在这个秃鹫石上识别出各种图像，认为它们是对构成黄道带的星座的描绘。但这些星座起源于巴比伦。所以他们不可能不知道巴比伦的黄道带。我的意思是，这实在是太明显了。出于所有这些原因，我认为这不大可能。
There's a further problem, which is what exactly is the catastrophe? Is it the melting of the ice caps? Is it the fact that... It's a comet, isn't it? It's a comet. I read that out at the beginning of episode one. Right the ice caps is it the fact that it's a comet i read that out at the beginning of episode one right so this is his latest iteration but before that he thought that it had it was a continent that had moved and ended up under antarctica okay and then it got proved that actually antarctica's been under ice for for millions of years so that couldn't be possible yeah so i think that's all i think it's all clearly mad but having said that at the end of last episode i said that there were areas in which I think Hancock is actually fascinating.
还有一个更进一步的问题，那就是：究竟什么是灾难？是冰盖融化吗？是因为……是一颗彗星，对吧？是一颗彗星。我在第一集开头读过那个。对的，是冰盖吗？是因为它是一颗彗星吗？我在第一集开头读过那个。对的，所以这是他最新的说法。但在此之前，他认为那是一块移动并最终落入南极洲底部的陆地。好吧，然后事实证明南极洲实际上在冰下数百万年了，所以这是不可能的。是的，所以我想这一切，我认为这一切显然都是疯狂的。话虽如此，在上一集结束时，我曾说过，在某些方面我认为汉考克实际上非常迷人。
Yeah. And I think that there are aspects of his case that do get us back, ironically, to the mindset of Plato. Ooh, that's a comparison I didn't expect. Well, so this idea of the comet, this is from the Timaeus. In the Timaeus, the Egyptian priests tell Solon, their Athenian visitor, that Phaeton in his chariot, driving the chariot of the sun, burning the earth, that this is actually a folk memory of a comet. So Graham Hancock is kind of being true to the story there, I think.
是的。我认为他的论点的某些方面，讽刺的是，确实把我们拉回了柏拉图的心态。噢，这是一个我没料到的比较。好吧，所以这个关于彗星的想法，来自《蒂迈欧篇》。在《蒂迈欧篇》中，埃及祭司告诉他们的雅典访客梭伦，法厄同驾着太阳战车，烧灼着大地，这实际上是关于彗星的民间记忆。所以格雷姆·汉考克在那里可以说是忠于这个故事的，我认为。
Right. And I think also Plato's great idea was, certainly in the Republic, if not in the Timaeus, was this idea of there being philosopher kings, people of such transcendent wisdom that they should have the guidance of people who are more ignorant and less suited to looking after themselves. His idea, which derives from Donnelly, that civilization originates with kind of nautical philosopher kings, philosopher kings who are going around on the ships and scattering the seed of civilization. Again, that's quite platonic. And I do think that one of the problems that historians, archaeologists, whatever, of very ancient cultures face is that scholarship is founded on traditions of objectivity and scrupulous study that can remove the people who do it from the philosophical or the religious
对的。而且我认为柏拉图的伟大思想——当然是在《理想国》中，如果不是在《蒂迈欧篇》中的话——就是哲人王的理念，那些拥有超越智慧的人，应该去指导那些更加无知、不擅长照顾自己的人。他的观点源自唐利，即文明起源于某种航海的哲人王，这些哲人王乘着船四处航行，播撒文明的种子。同样，这也是非常柏拉图式的。我确实认为，历史学家、考古学家无论对极其古老的文化持何种态度，面临的一个问题是：学术建立在客观性和审慎研究的传统之上，这可能会将从事这项工作的人与这些故事最初诞生的哲学、宗教、文化或神话背景隔离开来。这就是为什么那些极其疯狂的理论，往往能比更加审慎、客观、准确的学术叙事，更接近这些神话最初讲述时的精神。这里面有一种奇怪的悖论。
or the cultural or the mythological context in which these stories may have originated. And that's why the kind of the very mad theories, often they can get you back closer to the original spirit in which these myths were told often than the much more scrupulous, objective, accurate scholarly accounts do. And that's a kind of strange paradox there yeah plato and his original audience would have relished magicians of the gods and yes i think apocalypse whereas they would have found the bulletin of you know archaeological studies very tedious and i think they would have found it much easier to to recognize graham hancock's ancient apocalypse right as as being true to to the story then yes exactly as you say the kind of the
是的，柏拉图和他的最初受众会很乐意享用《众神之魔术师》和《远古启示录》，是的，而他们会觉得（中东史前考古学）公报非常乏味。我认为他们会更容易发现格雷姆·汉考克的《远古启示录》对故事是忠实的，然后，是的，正如你所说的那种中东史前考古学公报。好吧，这可不是我料想你会得出的结论——你基本上花了两个小时来证明柏拉图会真的很喜欢格雷姆·汉考克的系列节目。我不是那个意思。我怀疑柏拉图会有时间看网飞吗？你觉得他会去体育馆谈论……在体育馆里，在学园里和年轻人闲逛？也许他会，是的。也许他会谈论，你知道的，理想形式和理想国家以及所有这些东西。我想他会谈论灵魂不朽。我想他会。但即使是柏拉图也会放松一下，不是吗？
bulletin for mid-east prehistory archaeology well that is not the conclusion i expected you to reach that basically you spent two hours proving that plato would have really enjoyed graham ancock's series i'm not saying that i'm i'm not i doubt plato would have had time for for netflix do you think uh he'd have been down the gymnasium talking about down in the gym down in the academy hanging out with the lads maybe he would yeah maybe he would talking about you know ideal forms and ideal state and all that kind of stuff i suppose he would immortality of the soul i suppose he would but even playtime would have relaxed wouldn wouldn't he?
他可能会说，是的，好吧，他会办一场欢宴。也许他会邀请格雷姆·汉考克参加欢宴。格雷姆·汉考克……网飞与放松。这正是柏拉图所热衷的。
He might have said, yeah, well, he'd have had a symposium. Maybe he'd have invited Graham Hancock for a symposium. Graham Hancock ground for a Netflix and chill. That's what Plato would have been, would have been all about.
所以，我的意思是，你觉得亚特兰蒂斯这事会……现在它是不是已经变成了一个笑话？无意冒犯格雷姆·汉考克，但这是不是已经变成了一个笑话，以至于它基本上已经没有后劲了？这只是19和20世纪的一种执念。
So, I mean, do you think the Atlantis thing will just, has it become such a joke now? No offense to Graham Hancock, but has it become such a joke that it's basically, Graham Hancock, but has it become such a joke that it doesn't have any legs? And it was a 19th and 20th century obsession.
有点像雪人或者香格里拉之类的东西。是的，我想是的。人们在23世纪不会再谈论它了，对吧？好吧，我的意思是，格雷姆·汉考克的系列节目大获成功。我的意思是，显然有这方面的市场需求。
A bit like the Yeti or something, or Shangri-La. Yeah, I think so. People aren't going to be talking about it in the 23rd century, are they? Well, I mean, Graham Hancock's series did fantastically well. I mean, there's clearly an appetite for it.
它制作得很好，不是吗？很多人说，哦，好吧，你一定在里面发现了什么。不过他们真的会这么说吗？还是说这极具娱乐性，简直就像《历史的余烬》一样？不，因为他上了乔·罗根的节目。我看到了。去跟一个名字叫弗林·迪布尔的杰出考古学家辩论。这绝对是命名宿命论的一个绝佳例子，不是吗？弗林·迪布尔肯定是你能在当地历史博物馆的抽屉里找到的某种极其无聊的古器物。我不知道。不管怎样，但这会非常令人兴奋。所以我想很多人都在听乔·罗根的节目，不是吗？甚至比听《历史的余烬》的人还要多。如果格雷姆·汉考克能够在对阵弗林·迪布尔时守住阵地……好吧，那么也许他有资格在我们播客里占一个位置，汤姆。谁知道呢？我们可以把他们两个都请来，对吧？太好了。让我们把他们都请来。好吧。
It was very well made, isn't it? Lots of people say, oh, well, you must have something there. Do they say that, though? Or do they say this was immensely entertaining tosh, not unlike the rest is history? No, because he's going on the Joe Rogan show. I saw that. To debate it with an archaeologist with the splendid name of Flint Dibble. That's a brilliant example of nominative determinism isn't it surely flint dibble is a particular kind of incredibly boring artifact you find in a drawer
带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，那真是太迷人了。非常有趣。这确实是一面非常有趣的镜子，折射出人们不断变化的执念。我认为这也相当有趣，因为在我们做亚特兰蒂斯专题之前，我们请来了彼得·弗兰科潘谈论气候末日。所以我们没有讨论的一个方面是，也许我们正在回到柏拉图讲述的故事的最初核心——亚特兰蒂斯是一个关于傲慢与复仇的寓言。是的，这与以下环境焦虑非常吻合：
at a local history museum i don't know anyway well but it'll be very exciting so i guess lots of people listen to joe rogan don't they, even more than listen to the rest of the history. And if Graham Hancock is able to hold his own against Flint Dibble. Well, but then maybe he'll qualify for a slot on our podcast, Tom. Who knows? We'd get them both, couldn't we? Good. Let's get them all. All right.
我们作为一个物种变得过于成功了，我们正在被我们自己的技术所摧毁。好吧，伴随着这个重磅炸弹，或者更确切地说，伴随着那场海啸，我们说，谢谢收听《历史的余烬》，我们下次再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要收听独家番外、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
On that bombshell, Tom, that was absolutely fascinating. Very entertaining. It was genuinely a really interesting mirror onto sort of people's changing obsessions. I think also kind of quite interesting because before we did the Atlantis ones, we had Peter Frankopan on talking about climate apocalypse. So that's something we didn't discuss was the way in which maybe we're getting back to the original point of the story that Plato told that Atlantis is a parable about hubris and a nemesis yes it kind of maps quite well onto the environmental anxieties about
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、番外节目和抢先购买门票，请前往……本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
the fact that we basically just become too successful as a species that we're being destroyed by our own technology all right on that bombshell or rather on that tsunami uh we say um thank you for listening to the rest is history and we'll be back next time goodbye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening and access to our chat community please sign up up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
事实上，我们作为一个物种实在太成功了，以至于我们正在被自己的技术所毁灭。好吧，带着这个重磅炸弹，或者说海啸般的讯息，呃，我们说，谢谢大家收听《The Rest Is History》，我们下期再见，再见，拜拜。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听独家加更节目、提前收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works We have just launched our Members Club if you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点娱乐圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，向大家展示它的运作方式。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目和提前
access to live tickets, head to There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
购买现场演出门票的特权，请前往……该集目前尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。